[Music]
in found it news would you find it I'll
tell you what if I submitted by two bros
chillin in the hot tub all the gates
although that's gay
that's you and Joe we never do that
before I have a [ __ ] log of you in
this guy in the hot tub he was wearing a
hat in the hot tub
was it for a bit no it was concerning
time or kickboxing yes you had a hat on
Oh hot tub okay
bathtub yeah yeah hot tub it's like five
boroughs children in a hot tub hey we
get naked and hang out in the hot tub I
didn't think it was anything weird all I
said it's just you two that's all I said
and you guys took it to be like I heard
because Bart said gay told you to all
right a woman's lost contact lens found
in her eyelid 20 years late 28 years
later I've been around for 28 years yeah
Wow what do you mean maybe even longer
and then let's put it off for that long
they have like glass ones yeah it was
glass ones first that's what she had
what I'm surprised I should didn't get
infected or bother her eye or anything
because those are really thick and it
gets lodged in it I've had it longer
than that breaking like stab her eyeball
yeah and you feel it like it's never
just not I've got it stuck back there
before
yeah me too and then one morning I woke
up and it like it came you were content
I used to not I see how now but then
before I was like some guy should be up
there have to go what I seal it so it's
a little bit different than LASIK
basically it's a laser and I kind of
like shapes your cornea I seal that make
a little incision and they pretty much
just pop a new lens inside gotcha
and they also started the ice bucket
challenge yes does that [ __ ] bucket
challenge huh did you have to heal for a
while uh no actually the healing process
is shorter than LASIK it was like a
month you said because you would touch
an ascender I don't know two weeks to
heal but a month to go full-blown like I
so that's a month to you all right so
this woman here she's 42 years old but
she lost her contact lens back when she
was 14 years old she's from the UK so
she was she asked oh she was playing a
game of badminton and she got hit really
hard in her left eye and then that's
when it dislodged the contact she lost
it she forgot about it all these years
but then recently she went to an
ophthalmologist because her left eye lid
was drooping a lot yeah and it had been
for many many years but then at this
point now it was just like it was just
really so she lived most of her life
with a lazy eye
yeah just a stuck [ __ ] contact this
white go to the doctor sometimes folks
you go to the doctors chill oh really
Steve green if I had a droopy eye you
put your acid be at the dark I don't
know about that you probably must fine
I'll go away no I would not it's fine
she had a droopy eye and thought that it
was just a batman neck Siddhant yeah oh
yeah badminton dude who gets an accident
during badminton - that's true it was a
mean game of Batman yes like the [ __ ]
is sporting rice to play with my mom
little tiny little guy birdie
yeah it's like tennis right it's like a
it's like a ball with a [ __ ] it's
more like volleyball it's more like
volleyball but it's at with racquets
dude I could never hit that thing for
more than one turn it was like we do it
in class
it's like ping-pong hacky sack yeah it
doesn't touch the floor I have to keep
it in there they try to like smack it
down on people Halep tennis volleyball
yeah so she when she went in they
discovered they did an x-ray thing and
they saw that I like x-ray things things
great thing you know wow
discovered assist yo she has a nice
brain can we just appreciate that for us
a sexy brain that brain is nice and
filled Sam girl that's what they mean
when they like and you just love me more
my [ __ ] brain yeah we like her brain
a niche if she's smart they say that she
gives good brain right this girl gives
good brain I never met a girl who gives
good brain wide I'll skip it you want to
rephrase that you want to rephrase that
well you want to have a bad day I think
what's have a bad leave to be honest no
one of these Inger I wasn't worth it
it's not yeah you made the whole room
quiet it's never worth it Steve it's
never like Joe has your back right now
that's all are you that's a girl that's
a girl but does it make me horny yeah it
doesn't make me horny knows if she
follows it's exposed to like that's you
could Google you go beyond naked it's
like it's like when you got a queer game
boy just goes to show underneath all of
it we're all the same
yeah oh wow I wonder if we have good
brains like that out yes this here which
a seeds assist so then when the doctor
surgically removed the cyst the cyst
burst and found like a perfectly fine
contact with hard-code I was protecting
her eyeball this isn't like I was
protecting her eyeball because it really
go for it yeah that's insane dude this
one's given me the freaking creep I feel
it in my I know it freaks me out more
than like foreign objects like I could
do a little metal or plastic but
parasites is what really freaks me well
yeah like all the answers of the
[ __ ] night you know ever since
we did that job was welcomed a hood rat
bag creatures of the creatures of the
night ever since we did ijk news about
how there's this one parasite in cat
poop my cat keeps pooping on our bed
what what yeah and then look before so
before it was cutting no so before it
was kind of cute because he was like
communicating Liam how he was
communicating with us that our kitty
litter was that his kitty litter woody
who dirty like hey
[ __ ] clean it so we'd be like
all of those pooping again we have to
clean the the kitty litter so we would
clean it but now he's been getting into
this habit of just taking the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] actually could we catch him right
before he's about it to the show you
start scratching this [ __ ] was doing
it in the middle of a sleeping when it
woke me up on your bed on my bed like
you and your designer Casey said Casey
said no big he's actually pretty polite
because if there's anything on that side
where usually poops like if there's
someone's jacket or a t-shirt he'll poop
like away from that area looks pretty
nice cover your bed with clothes I know
no now what we've been doing is keeping
our door closed and we're like yeah we
like cuddling with the cats but he's
punished right now he can't what if you
get another box of litter now they know
they have to please we had three don't
be soft on these cats
you're being soft on these cats our cat
peed on our bed in front of us we walked
right wrong to our bed and peed on on it
and we took his dumb ass to the vet to
teach us barred me across my chest
I thought you peed on him we would know
he just he's terrified of going to this
yeah ever cage straight as [ __ ] and he
has never done it since oh he did do it
again after that what when no because
then we got the second litter box yeah
yeah so then we were thinking this most
recent episode of pooping and clean
kitty litters we were thinking cuz we
moved one of the kitty litters all three
of them were downstairs there was
there's to be one upstairs but Isaac
doesn't really have a lot of room in his
bathroom so then we moved that one away
so we thought maybe he's telling us he
wants that one back up here so we moved
it back and he's still pooping uh-oh and
I'm always thinking like [ __ ] I don't
want to catch that parasite so I have to
keep taking me you should put three
little boxes and Isis pepper
a man with a cats thing you know it's
real pain yeah I used to watch that show
mystery diagnosis and this guy went to
sleep had headache and went to sleep
woke up blind and they couldn't figure
it out for like 20-something years it
turns out it was because he jumped in
his pool and his pool had some sort of
parasite in it randomly and but I want a
house with the pool I know me too with
this freaks me out at the clean which I
have a pool overall it was a little bit
dirty I think and this guy's pool cage
fan was off and like a parasite swam up
his canal thing and and it like ate
something back there and like just
blinded him no I am scared attacks I
love opening my eyes in water
me too and [ __ ] your policy alright me
out Vegas everywhere know what they
exist everywhere
oh Jesus everywhere parasites are a part
of life you know that's why there's no
one to blind me every time I have a
headache I'm scared to go to sleep cuz I
know that's why we get allergic to [ __ ]
in our body be attacking like random
things like peanuts and all that because
our bodies used to having tons of
parasites to [ __ ] with and fight yeah
well now we don't have many things to
fight so then it starts fighting like
normal [ __ ] well it's sort of like how
how we are in civilization when we have
less to fight about right anybody give
each other we have I think about the
dumbest stupidest millennial world gets
the more you have to fight about exactly
what peanuts actually have some sort of
mold on them that most people can eat
but some people die yeah that's what
they're allergic - yeah same with
cashews and lactose like there's I don't
know if lactose as a mold but like you
know like on cheeses when it makes that
mold yeah like some people can't yeah
but yeah I don't know
28 years of the contact lens looking
right and it's just she always said like
yeah I just had droopy I just didn't
think it was a big deal
maybe so that's just along got contact
stuck in his eyes oh yeah and his faces
and they fell on his face - yeah like
that
oh he's paralyzing a baby it's only
funny cuz he's successful it's only
funny if it's success if the person is
successful and they're better than you
is it funny to say Michael Jackson was a
pedo no because he wasn't a pedophile
yeah he was angels successful is it okay
but he was an angel virgin but it's not
funny with his glove I love even if he
was I call conspiracy that's ignorant
Michael Jackson is not a parasite to
society by the way if you guys I don't
actually believe that by the way if you
think he's a parasite to society it's
just fun because there's some MJ fans
like yourself who are extremely like
violently like yeah pensive of him
you just chipped the piece of my soul
when you said that right there's so many
people that don't believe how do you
feel about earlier however tell you
about post Malone beating his record
yeah how did you feel about that
well that's a fair match and that's a
gentlemen's agreement so it's like if
someone got a gold medal in the Olympics
good job right but if if post Malone is
saying MJ is a pedophile I'll [ __ ] that
full up
I hadn't think it was Michael Jackson's
talk about some that was lodged in my
body that's still there now cuz I hey
Len yeah graph its graphite I'll have
that too right here I have a DC it's not
black dot oh yeah he's mom has been
someone I think is it lead or is it
graphite mines wood or graphite it's
like yeah [ __ ] anthony taylor was in
seventh grade pencils you know well at
least like the pencils that have the
lead or they call it lid yeah
no it's graphite it's a mechanical
pencil
yeah because Glen is poisonous we found
out that yeah that's graphite for sure
yeah I tell you what lead paint still
the best really it keeps the color
Mexican leg candy stop babe yeah with
you on that
I meant for Mexican LED candy there you
will see many more yeah but if has your
memory not so good is it no I know so
it's like the damage is done give me my
leg that's tight I like that